how do you come up with your video ideas  to keep your community engaged that's a  combination of what do I want to make  with what are people asking for and I  think that's at the success of any  successful business not just a YouTube  channel not just a podcast or a show  it's like what do you love doing with  where is their domain if you take  something that you just love doing but  nobody cares you have a hobby right it  could be a really fulfilling hobby but  it's just a hobby and if you take  something that everybody wants but you  don't really care about you're never  gonna win because you're doing work that  you hate and there's somebody else out  there who loves doing that thing and so  don't spend your time doing work that  you hate so it's in that combination of  like what do I love doing with what do  people actually want that every business  can become successful